and i've said this and i many many times
lebron james is a basketball player he's
not that smart listen to him talk
uh listen go read his twitter feed his
instagram he can barely spell but y'all
think
this guy is some kind of uh
thought leader public intellectual
whatever
and then the number one thing because i
you know his lack of
grammar and all that i could almost deal
with that but what what the media won't
deal with is that
muhammad ali whether we like the nation
of islam or not he was connected and
controlled by a religious sec
and elijah muhammad malcolm x whether we
like them or not
very smart people
ahead of the curve they control muhammad
ali said what they told him to say and
did what they told him to do at that
time lebron james ain't connected to
nobody but nike and phil knight phil
knight is not elijah muhammad or malcolm
x
and so who's who who's advised adam
mendelson or and i know adam mendelson
the pr guy that works behind but he
ain't malcolm x or elijah muhammad
expecting any of these these athletes
can barely keep up with their baby mamas
how the hell are they going to keep up
with what's going on in the rest of the
world
uh
it's just it's
we keep putting them in this position we
keep oh who gonna be the next muhammad
ali and and and we have to accept those
days are gone
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
sports analyst a culture critic and host
of the fairly new show fearless on blaze
tv jason whitlock welcome to round two
on the reuben report
i thought this was round three but maybe
i'm wrong maybe you know your interviews
are so long they just feel like two
rounds
oh he's starting in with a hook i'm
pretty sure this is round two
i think it's round two
all right well i got another shot you're
the sports guy you guys love stats you
guys love stats you sports people let me
throw another jab before you get started
i just want everybody to know watching
at home
uh a month ago or three weeks ago i
asked dave to come on my show to consent
to an interview
dave puts me off
i'm on vacation i'm doing this i'm doing
that i don't
and somehow
i end up on dave's show
before he comes on my show dave doesn't
say anything about you know i'll return
the favor or anything like that
it's just day being day well i guess so
here i am
i just wanted to get through this one
make sure it works out okay we're off to
a good start and then uh i'll gladly uh
swing by over there
all right
all right
well i'm probably going to
talk about the stuff i want to talk with
you about i'm probably going to talk
about it to now
it'll be over we'll just run a replay of
this interview on my show but anyway go
ahead i'm sorry i'm going to shut up and
listen to you it's your show i know
we'll have i have a feeling we'll find
some other things to talk about but but
there's actually a ton i want to talk to
you about because when i had you on and
i'm pretty sure it's only been once but
when i had you on in studio in la a
couple years back it's probably a good
three years ago already i mean time
flies especially these days um you know
it sort of felt like sports was in the
midst of this weird meltdown but it
didn't feel like it had fully melted
down and the racialization of everything
and the gender and football is gay and
all of the stuff that is out there now
so i guess my first question really is
what's your general take on what has
happened
to sports in general in the last couple
years i think i told you that i don't
watch anything anymore i do not watch
professional sports anymore that's very
sad to me i just can't take it anymore
dave i just had this discussion on my
show on wednesday
about because the nfl right now is
bragging about hey week one ratings uh
were up seven percent over a year ago
and the nfl is back and look at the tv
ratings and and
and what i'm arguing is like the nfl
in particular is america's comfort food
and america is in desperate need of
comfort right now because of
covid
uh
and because of the racial meltdown we've
had we're looking for anything
that reminds us of the way things used
to be
and so
i think the initial kind of rush back to
sports and football and filling up
stadiums and let's have fun
i i think that's what's happening people
are looking they they want some
nostalgia
they want some comfort
i do think and i and i argued this on
wednesday and and uncle jimmy and the
guests we had on dennis evans they both
pushed back against me but i do think
the passion for sports
has waned and faded i see it in myself
i don't like
or respect the athletes the way that i
used to and it's never
it's never that i used to think these
guys were the smartest guys on the
planet
but i also didn't think they were the
dumbest guys on the planet or the
easiest to control or totally controlled
by group think and social media i didn't
think they were frauds and phonies who
were just willing to say and do anything
to stay in the good graces of social
media and the elite overlords and that's
what i think now so i still watch the
sports
i don't feel as good about the athletes
and eventually and i made this analogy
it's like the old bb king song the
thrill is gone
and
sometimes
when you're ending a relationship you go
through this
part where you're not quite separated
you're still living in the same house
you're still going through the motions
but everybody knows it's over
and that's kind of how i feel about
uh professional sports i still watch i
still somewhat i love them i love the
games
but the passion for the athletes just
isn't the same as it used to be and
eventually i'll just spend less and less
time with sports
on a personal note how much does that
suck for you i mean not only is this
your job and you got into this stuff
because you love it i mean i was never a
sports analyst but i grew up watching
the same games you were watching like
loving that stuff and it kind of sucks
it kind of when i'm flipping on youtube
and i'm watching old nba games when it
wasn't political and then they show me a
new one i'm just like no i just don't
want to do it and it kind of sucks
no it it sucks big time dave uh because
for someone like me
who there's two things that have shaped
my world view
the church my grandmother and mother
raised me in
in football and playing sports because i
in high school i played at track and
field play a little basketball
intramural or whatever play foot i was
in the sports and the values taught in
sports and the values taught in my
church
there was great synergy and alignment
between them i'm looking at sports
betray all of those values
and it irritates the heck out of me it
bothers me immensely and so
this sucks to see something this central
to your core beliefs
completely pivot and give in to marxism
and
uh you know
authoritarian everybody must get the
facts or you face these harsh penalties
i just don't like any of it and yeah it
just and
it sucks big time
so the newest thing speaking of the vax
in the last couple days now the nba has
reached a deal somehow even though they
have over 100 employees that the players
will not have to be vaccinated i don't
understand how that makes any sense i'm
not for mandating vaccines just just so
you know that uh but they've they've
gotten this exemption but it appears
that the people who go to the games will
have to be vaccinated now i'm fairly
certain nba players might sweat on each
other spit on each other
do they have some sort of protections we
don't know about
they don't
this sounds
similar to what the nfl you don't have
to be vaccinated in the nfl
but you do face all these different set
of rules that the vaccinated players
don't face
that sounds like what the nba is going
to do it's stupid it makes no sense it's
no different than last year when no one
was vaccinated they're all in arena
the coach is wearing a mask for no
reason he pulls it down every time he
wants to really be heard and say
anything important and it was just it
was the masquerade theater that that
we've been seeing for the past 18 months
and they were doing it in nba so a guy
has to sit in a different place in the
locker room maybe he has to fly
somewhere differently on a plane but
when you get out on the court sweat and
bump into each other and slap high five
and sit next to each other on the bench
sweaty as you want to be
that's all fine but when we go in this
locker room go sit over here because
you're not vaccinated it's just stupid
and i'm i'm pretty sure you've heard the
same crazy rumors that i've heard about
when the nba was in the bubble right it
was called the bubble about all of the
girls that were getting smuggled into
the bubble like it's not like these
people did not live and i'm pretty sure
it didn't become a coveted super
spreader event
dave
and i hope i'm not cracking an
inappropriate joke i i don't i can't but
i'm not sure if you're aware i'm not
sure if you're aware but i've talked to
dr fauci about this personally
but
the covet virus cannot live inside of a
vagina
so
when the women were coming into the
bubble
and and you know their vagina is
completely pure
and
bacteria free covert free and so that
was perfectly understandable and safe
dave
i'm just going to make note of that
kovid cannot live in the vagina okay
well we got our promo out of you
whitlock
which uh
which sport you know we're talking about
the nba now but you mentioned the nfl
those seem to be the two that are having
this meltdown and by the way when you
mention the seven percent increase i'm
guessing that the year before ratings
were considerably more down from the
year before so it's it's sort of like a
like a not as great number right when
they're talking about that but which
sport do you think has suffered the most
from all this it seems like the nba to
me but i'm a little out of the loop
it's hard for me to say
who has suffered the most
i i would probably argue
i'm not going to say sports nfl players
have suffered the most
they
allowed ownership
to
jam a collective bargaining agreement
and a salary cap down their throat
before uh the tv deals were struck
and and it was all under the excuse
we'll cover it and you know we're not
going to generate as much money and so
even with all the money the nfl players
are making and they're making a ton
compared to what they used to and you
know guys like patrick holmes and dak
prescott are making more than 40 million
dollars a year
they're not making what they could and
should be making
if
the covert charade if they hadn't
damaged their business with the
george floyd colin kaepernick
let's piss off our traditional fan base
and so i'm not sure if i'm quite
answering your question but i would say
over the course of these
five or six years
the kaepernick charade
george floyd charade and now covet i
don't think any sport has been more
damaged than football players
and and and football and again i i i
i say that saying the full impact of
what they've done over the last five
years
is going to play out
over the next 10 years everybody right
now is you know early on football i love
it and i'm going to these games and it's
screw fouchy we're partying and acting
like it's 1999.
a bit when that dissipates and when
people are sitting there because i'm
tell week one of the nfl i'm sitting
around watching football it's what i was
built in this life to do watch football
talk about it used to play a little bit
of it in college
but i'm just not as passionate
and eventually that that lack of passion
once the thrill is gone the love is gone
and people understand like man i'm just
really putting money in some ungrateful
idiot's pockets uh
you know what i'm tired of doing this
and i'm gonna spend time with my wife
and kids or family i'm gonna go hunting
i'm gonna go fishing there's other
things to do
then watch people that you don't respect
play a game that's been softened up and
dramatically changed the the point i was
arguing on wednesday on my show is like
the nfl has made a bunch of decisions
over the past 10 years under roger
goodell
to satisfy its critics
they've changed the rules because of
head trauma and the new york times beat
them up over cte
uh you know they allowed kneeling
because of colin kaepernick because of
george floyd they passed plastered
all these marxist social justice slogans
all over everything
it it's
they're you know and people call me a
sexist pig but they're they're
decorating their
officiating crews with women
they're coaching staffs with women their
executive offices with women and they're
doing all this to stay a step ahead of
the me too feminist movement
and they're just piling on people and
i'm not saying look there i know some
women who love football i know but
they're just pacifying people
whose hearts really aren't in the game
and they're pacifying the people that
don't really love the game
and they're doing nothing to satisfy me
they're
a one
ride or die
football fan what about me they just
take me for granted and eventually guys
like i'm gonna join guys like you to
just say you know what i got better
things to do
so when they said the nfl is gay did you
have any clue as to what they meant by
that i mean they literally it was a
commercial the nfl is gay i know a
little bit about that but
i couldn't put it all together
uh
i
dave and and and
i want to be respectful because i but i
i say there's an alphabet mafia blm
lgbt i'm with you
that's the mafia now and
it's it's
everything is being done to say don't
attack me black lives matter
lgbt movement
don't attack me and so they you know the
nfl is going to say i'm gay i'm marxist
i'm going to say the cops are out
randomly killing black people
i i'm gonna say whatever i think is
necessary to keep you off my back
and
uh
listen i
grew up
as an idiot in a football locker room as
an athlete
uh i can't say i was as dumb as all the
guys i played sports with but i i'm
certainly remember i'm 54 dave i
certainly remember in my era
uh guys that were less
masculine than the standard were
mistreated
and i am
really glad and thankful that that has
changed and we're we're going a
different direction and everybody that
kind of bullying should not have been
tolerated then and i'm glad we're not
tolerating it now
but
i still think there needs to be i can't
be made to feel bad
of course because maybe i'm a little i
got a little bit more masculinity than
the normal person
and i'm just football is a masculine
game
it's not about your sexuality for
someone like myself dave
i think we've all gone overboard with
our sexual identities
and we're all wearing them on our sleeve
and it's like the first thing we tell
people i'm heterosexual and boy do i
like
vaginas
and
yeah
plus with the kobe thing you told me
before you know yeah
it's like
and and dave i i
the key to saving this country because i
do believe like the country's at stake i
do
we have to go back to
hey
i'm a christian or i'm an american
let that be your initial identity
rather than your sexual identity because
i just don't think what arouses us
sexually
is all that important and i'll say this
as a christian
and who was someone who i think as a kid
and as a young person
could be accurately described as
homophobic
and and i i regret that and i regret
that as a christian because
regardless of what i think about
homosexuality
it's no different for me as a christian
than my promuscuity outside of marriage
and so
it was wrong to try us as christians
that have these certain beliefs to try
to say our sin isn't as bad as their sin
and and
it's how we have cr we have created and
i blame us as christians for not being
more tolerant and more understanding
we've created this backlash
and
uh the alphabet mafia
and and now i've seen people rather than
admitting their flaws
and then doing the right thing i see the
nfl and other sports leagues bending
over backwards and doing things that
they really don't believe
to pacify
social media the twitter mob
and
all the other people that are allegedly
on the right side of history
yeah well jason let me say this as an
american you get no judgment uh from me
on any of your past judgments let me
just be very very clear about that was
it not joe namath who said i was a gay
marxist was it not him wasn't he a big
gay mark sister am i confusing him with
somebody else
joe
joe neighbor did not was it it wasn't
joe namath what was it
let me ask you
i'm guessing you you talked to to
players in these leagues uh probably
probably on the dl uh but i i have a
friend or two that's in the nba and i
know that that guys are not happy about
this they are not happy about the
politics in the sports they're not happy
about the the influence of china there's
a couple people that that privately will
talk about this not much not many that
will talk about it publicly and
certainly most of the coaches and and
steve kerr and popovich and lebron
obviously just just loving on china all
day long but do you sense players are
angry about all of this stuff too
i think where players have gotten more
aggressive
and is still not aggressive enough
the vaccine push
has really pushed guys to the brink
and it's like this is a bridge too far
and i've bitten my i i bit my tongue and
held my
thoughts on the political stuff and and
everybody sitting around acting like
america's the most evil place on the
planet that
they struggled with that but they were
able to ho but now it's about injecting
things into my body
when you're talking about the the young
some of the youngest healthiest most in
shape people on the planet their you the
the death rate the damage rate for
covert for these people is virtually
non-existent
and so i have seen a growing discontent
there and i think it's helping them
realize like oh
so when we accepted
the kneeling
and the national anthem
we never thought it would get here and
now they're starting yeah that's why you
got to draw a line in the sand on all
this stuff because eventually it is
going to come for you
and and so i i do think there's a lot of
players that know like
man
you know what i'm able to do for my
family because of football and
basketball and america's passion for
sports
why are we sitting up here like we
are the people the most irate and think
america is evil yeah i i i've heard from
enough players particularly during this
vaccine thing
that
it's it's going too far
and they know how hypocritical it is
they know that it's driven by
the players who are addicted to social
media
and and you know would would rather die
than do anything that didn't get a
thousand likes and 500 retweets
and and
i i
but what most people are doing and this
is
their father the players are following
the lead
of roger goodell
uh the executives in the nfl the owner
everybody's just trying to do
what's best for them in the moment roger
goodell he doesn't want to do what's
best for football
he wants to do what's best for him to
survive in a job that pays him 40
million dollars a year if he can squeeze
six
ten more years out of that
who care and in football's in a mess
when he leaves that's someone else's
problem to fix
he's made his money and that's what
players
mimicking the leadership they're seeing
from roger goodell mimicking the
leadership they see from ownership
if i can stick in this another five ten
years and the value of this franchise
goes up i can sell and get out and turn
it over to someone else no one's doing
what's best for the games anymore it's
just what there's so much money at stake
everybody it's no different than what we
see in politics dave all the politicians
they're doing what's ever best
however long their political career
lasts they can make enough money or set
themselves up to make enough money on
the other side can i get that tv job at
msnbc or cnn or fox news everybody's
just doing what's best for them
no one
can
dave i think about this all the time
john f kennedy in 1961 ask not
what uh your country can do for you ask
what you're what you can do for your
country
we're so far away from that
that
no one asked themselves that question
and if they did they would get thrown
out of politics
right it's i always say it's it's the
180 from what bernie and the left has
been selling if he went on stage and
said that or any lefty went on stage and
said that
they'd basically be strung up
they say what can we give you hey let us
know
we'll give you some stuff so what would
you do if you could take over i mean if
you could take over for goodell or uh
what is it adam silver or the nba give
me like one or two things that you might
do that would that would help the league
for longevity's sake and not just for
the immediacy of cashing out
what i would do dave to be hon and this
is particularly as it relates to
football because football
is the most powerful thing in popular
culture it's the number one show on five
different television networks buy a mile
and so that makes it far more powerful
than michael jackson or whatever
entertainer the cosby show whatever was
ever used to be the most popular nothing
compares to the nfl number one show on
five different tv networks
and so my mentality as it related to the
nfl as commissioner would be
and i really would and
what how can i use football to help
improve america that would be at the top
of my agenda and then
what could i do
to
serve my ownership
and and put football in the best
position possible and so
i would use football as my bully pulpit
and i would take all the slings and
arrows
and i would
there's nothing we would do that would
be satisfying to black lives matter
football is about unity
every coach goes into the locker room it
don't matter what color you are it don't
matter what neighborhood you came from
it doesn't matter if you're rural a city
kid whatever if your parents were rich
if your parents were poor
we come together as a team
my message as the nfl that's what we're
about we're not all over oh oh you're
black there's a special little set-aside
program we have for you
and we have to make you feel special and
blah football has never been about that
america and i don't care what people say
by declaration of independence and by
constitution i'm not talking about how
people
actually
ignored what was in the declaration of
independence ignored what was in the
constitution
but america was set up
that way
i don't care what color you are i don't
care
amer that's what america's intent is to
operate the way sports have
traditionally operated that's why there
was always so much racial progress in
sports and sports used to be a leader in
this country jackie robinson in 1947
breaking the color barrier that's what
inspired dr king and the civil rights
movements of the 50s and 60s sports used
to be a leader
in america
and
now we're followers of big tech
and we're followers of the globalist
uh corporations that
are far more worried about china
than they are about america and that's
why i think football's in such a unique
position the nfl doesn't need china and
it can still be a leader and so
i would
you know
go back and lean back into what pete
roselle
the greatest commissioner in all of
sports
what he did he he attached
football to americana and to patriotism
and he did all these things because he
knew that was their way
of undermining or surpassing major
league baseball and i would just lean
back into all those traditional values
that made football great and made it
what it is and i would stand firm and i
would and i mean the difference between
me and roger goodell is there's none of
these idiots at espn there's none of
these idiots in the new york times none
of them can out talk me on race they
they can't do it i've listened to them
i've re hannah nicole jones and the
little stupid 16 19 project i can go all
day with these guys and and crush
tonight
that's why they're all cowards
they will not these people they won't
come on
and engage with people that disagree
with them they can stand toe to toe with
them they won't be mesmerized by their
little word salads and would just keep
it real you couldn't you get one of
these black clowns on liberal clowns
that go on tv and and said oh my god the
police
are uh doing this and that and i'm like
what hood have you been in because i can
tell you where i came from i can tell
you where my daddy's business was in the
hood and we spent no time talking about
oh my god the police may kill me tonight
oh that's some [ __ ] and i would call
it out so you can't run you're a little
suburban ivy league negro
who speculating about what goes on in
the hood
i actually lived there i actually
understand i still got family there it's
not something i just go visit
maybe at thanksgiving or whatever and so
i would clown suit
the media and anybody else who
challenged me on these issues i'd be i
would still be writing a column as the
commissioner of the nfl and anybody that
opened up their mouth and wanted to give
me any lip i just light them up in a
column and explain to them okay deal
with that
uh because i've seen dave i've seen
people
this is one of the craziest things i saw
in in the media i saw a guy on tv
that told a story
i think during the height of the george
floyd or
one of these eric garner one of these
moments
went on tv
and said
that he and his wife had decided
that they would no longer let their 18
year old son
drive a car because they were so
petrified of the police
and
and i was just sitting there and again
this is the kind of if i was the
commissioner of one of these sports i
would clown suit this guy because i
would just go hold on man
you're so afraid of the police that
you're not gonna let your black son
drive a car
are you gonna let him go to a party with
other black boys
because statistically
his chances of being killed by somebody
are a thousand times greater
by another 18 year old black boy
than the police so maybe you should pass
a you can't run around with black boys
and then i now go ahead and respond to
that that i would and they wouldn't have
they would have nothing to say america
could see these are clowns these are
people that are just saying [ __ ] on tv
to draw attention to themselves to to
make sure that the checks come in from
msnbc china nike whoever uh but this
isn't the truth
and so if i was a commissioner of the
nfl i just stand on truth
and and i would you know but roger good
he's not equipped for this argument or
this time and you know ownership scared
but at some point uh dave men are gonna
have to be men again
and men
that
understand how good this country has
been to us and our families are going to
have to stand up
and and
fight this fight and quit hiding it's
one of the main reasons i left corporate
media because i you know
i wanted to get in the fight for real i
want the gloves off and let's let's pick
up these muskets and let's mow down some
of these idiots that are trying to tear
this country down
so i'm guessing you're not getting any
calls from uh good old joy anne reed
over at msnbc for these conversations
i wish she would call me dave
because what i would like to i'd like to
introduce her to a beautician who could
get her to settle on a hairstyle
uh because every time you turn on that
damn tv she got a new hairstyle new wig
she's culture she's culturally
appropriated from every race on the
planet with her hairstyle one day is
wilma roonel
[Laughter]
flintstone flintstones
yeah yeah yeah what was what was
who barney rubble rubble
you just never know from day to day
who's who she going culturally
appropriate from hairstyle to hairstyle
and then i mean and she's one of the
biggest phonies
on tv
if
her old blogs are what she really thinks
this woman was raised in the church just
like me yeah she's on tv lying
pretending that she's some kind of
leftist and and and it's all the
collected check and it
those are the those are the real
sellouts
those are the people selling out what
they really believe for money and then
they sit around and they want to call
tim scott they want to call him
more
and all this
so yeah no i won't be getting a call
from joyrie
yeah and i you know not that not the
twitter is much of a barometer of
anything other than the general hate of
the world but you know i see what people
say to you we we talked about it last
time you know you you'll make a
political comment or a sports or a
societal comment and then the things
that they will say to you as a black man
the supposedly tolerant people it's it's
just extraordinary and it just it just
never ends
dave i've
said it for a long time and i've got
some
awesome
liberal friends
awesome yeah
but
i have
always
faced
discrimination bigotry jealousy
from white liberals
that's been the story of my career now
there have been some that have been
tremendous to me and i've written about
them called them out by name but overall
what the white liberal how they feel
comfortable helping black people it's
like oh can i bend over and help you out
poor negro
and then when i help you out
make sure you put it on your resume that
i helped you out and maybe i'm gonna
tell everybody and and and you know what
for me helping you out
never say a word i disagree with
because if you do exactly you've sold me
out
and you're an ungrateful person
and
i just
i don't want to generalize but you know
about conservatives but what
conservatives have generally done in
this business as it relates to me is
like oh man how can we make money
that that's that's it it's it's
what you need how can we make money
with
the liberal it's
hey man you got to pledge allegiance to
everything that i believe in
and then
we can make some money but you better
thank me every day when you come in here
that i allowed you to make this money
and
i just yeah
that's what i think
no i i got you i got you uh you'll
appreciate this couple days ago because
i told you i don't i don't watch the new
games anymore i watch these old games on
youtube and i was watching the 92 finals
you know that's the jordan shrug year
and they're they're interviewing clyde
the glide i've got a ball sign from him
right behind me here and they start
asking him about race
out of nowhere and and you may remember
clyde never had an opinion on anything
he never really commented on anything it
wasn't his it wasn't his thing and they
keep trying to get him to comment on
race and then they go uh it's a white
interviewer by the way he's still in the
biz i'll tell you who he is after it's
not we don't need to throw him under the
bus right now uh and he goes he goes
well jordan you know with all his
success and all his influence like
shouldn't he be doing more to make sure
racism doesn't exist in america and
everything else and clyde who never said
anything really interesting outside of
basketball he goes you know he's a
basketball player he's working on his
craft he's not a politician and i was so
freaking relieved to hear it that this
guy who i love because of his skill said
something sensible and that was 1992 30
years ago you could say something
sensible and you wouldn't be now he
would be called to sell out for saying
that basically
and potentially run out of the nba he
would definitely get a suspension they
come up with some reason to suspend him
how dare you
say that racism isn't
the number one thing and that michael
jordan who's a basketball player must
take a position on that
it what clyde said there is 1 000
sensible
look
it's so hard to compete at the level
that jordan clyde drexer and these guys
did
if people think
that when jordan's at the height of his
career
that he's also studying up on
geopolitical issues and domestic issues
the god just had some self-awareness
like i'm gonna stay in my lane
i'm a basketball player right now why
don't y'all go ask
uh the politicians or
the the historians or activists or
whatever why are you asking me as a
basketball player and it's one of those
selfish things
that we in the media did
because we all
this generation the generation of sports
journalists that didn't
get to cover muhammad ali
didn't get to cover
uh the impact of the vietnam war and the
civil rights movement on america
those of us that didn't we want to redo
it and we want to turn lebron james into
muhammad ali and i've said this and
many many times
lebron james is a basketball player he's
not that smart listen to him talk
listen go read his twitter feed his
instagram he can barely spell but y'all
think
this guy is some kind of uh
thought leader public intellectual
whatever
and then the number one thing because i
you know his lack of grammar and all
that i can almost deal with that but
what what the media
won't deal with is that
muhammad ali whether we like the nation
of islam or not he was connected and
controlled by a religious sec
and elijah muhammad malcolm x whether we
like them or not
very smart people
ahead of the curve they control muhammad
ali said what they told him to say and
did what they told him to do at that
time lebron james ain't connected to
nobody but nike and phil knight phil
knight is not elijah muhammad or malcolm
x
and so who's
who who's advised adam mendelson or and
i know adam mendelson the pr guy that
works behind but he ain't malcolm x or
elijah muhammad
expecting any of these these athletes
can barely keep up with their baby mamas
how the hell they gonna keep up with
what's going on in the rest of the world
uh
it's just it's
we keep putting them in this position we
keep oh who gonna be the next muhammad
ali and and and we have to accept those
days are gone
the athletes today
make millions of dollars
live in gated communities
next to people who look like dave rubin
and they're not
in the hood they're not connected to the
working class
black americans or white americans the
way they used to be
these are the elites they've been led
into the club
that's why they go through these little
rituals uh
of putting dresses on like russell
westbrook and everybody go through these
humiliation rituals uh so they can be
led into the club
they're not speaking for the working
class person anymore they're speaking
for nike they're speaking for china
they're speaking for their pocketbooks
we need to cut it out
asking these guys to do things they're
incapable of doing i almost feel sorry
for them it's like it would almost be
like uh
if somebody asked hey spend the night at
mcdonald's and never eat a double fillet
fish sandwich
it's not gonna happen today it's not
gonna happen i do i do like the filleto
fish that's tartar sauce it's tangy
it's delicious
uh i want to talk to you about tech and
a couple other things but is there
anything else going on in the sports
world that's just got you going at the
moment
no i think we got it
we got the big stuff all right yeah i
think we got it
so so the tech stuff let's let's do a
little bit of that because you
years ago now everybody's sort of like
oh twitter's evil and it's it's what's
causing all of this chaos and you know i
just did this month off and what i kept
thinking was i don't mind doing videos i
don't mind being on posting pictures of
food it's something about twitter that
is making everything melt down um
how do you feel about the state of tech
at the moment and the way that we are
being manipulated whether we know it or
not
i think that
twitter's grip on public discourse
is leading america and the world
straight to hell it has so dumbed down
uh the conversation
and it's so reliant on spectacle all and
twitter
is
it's not just twitter but tick tock
the reels on instagram
every we
our phones
have so much stuff loaded into them
that's
supposed to keep us
our attention away from what's really
going on
to spectacle in hey who's dancing on
tick-tock
who's whose butt looks the best on
instagram uh who has said the most
racially divisive thing on twitter who
has spotted an alleged karen who has
mistreated
a black bird watcher
we are so hyper focused on things that
don't matter
and we're not smart enough to say hey
man the puppet masters want us focused
on things that don't matter
and we keep
giving them what they want and they keep
getting to do whatever they they they're
putting as much money as they want
they're selling us out to china and god
know who else
they're they're they're abandoning
americans over in afghanistan
they
they
they're labeling
uh a a protest
at the capitol an insurrection
and and we're going for because twitter
said so and there's this viral video and
if you don't hop on
oh my god you're questioning
whether or not uh you should take the
vaccine oh my god we'll suspend you from
twitter
they are in control of the conversation
they're dictating what's appropriate
conversation what's appropriate thoughts
to have
the whole point particularly as a
journalist
you question everything
that's the job of a journalist i was
told in
college it was one of the cliches
mantras of of journalism if your mother
says she loves you get a second opinion
that's what journalists are supposed to
do
twitter
facebook all of them now
nah there's some things you can't
question
if if and it's it's crazy dave
the vaccine in my opinion is meant for
overweight
people 50 and above like me that's what
it's meant for
no one should be forcing a 25 year old
in great physical condition or even if
they're in moderate or
bad they shouldn't be forcing the 25
year old to take a vaccine that's meant
for me
and people should be able to say that
over social media without a twitter mob
or getting suspended or twitter posted
all this is misinformation
of course the same things that
jason whitlock should do of course
cole beasley or
lamar jackson or one of these
perfectly healthy nfl players they
should do the exact same thing it's
that's never been true that's never what
america's been about
twitter is
the home of group think in the home of
control it's where the media go every
dumb
fake narrative
that the mainstream media corporate
media comes up with
twitter is its justification for it well
it's trending over twitter it's you know
lebron said black men are getting hunted
every time they go out look that's the
way black people believe
and it and that's the other thing dave
it's
i don't know if this relates directly
i'm sure it does relate directly to big
tech but
we're building a ward dave
based off of feelings
and desires oh someone feels this way
we better make rules to back them up and
so you know what if people feel that the
police are killing black men even though
the stats say otherwise
well they feel that way so let's change
the laws let's change the rules let's
pretend like it's a crisis now we're
going to step over a thousand dead
bodies in chicago and new york and
baltimore and everywhere but
this george floyd body that's special
and we got to do something about it yes
we have just stepped across a 12 year
old kid that was slaughtered by gang
violence a four-year-old little girl
that got us caught a stray bullet from
gang violence we're going to step over
all those and make sure we address this
one thing twitter justifies that twitter
the algorithms and it's all
rigged up in my opinion to make us think
that
george floyd is reality and everyday
reality
and
uh some
14 year old kid getting slaughtered and
gang
that's lightning that's lightning that's
getting struck by lightning that never
happens ignore that
right right or if you talk about how
many people got shot in chicago you're
the racist for bringing it up that's
very rare that's the other one
because dave i'll just say this what you
don't understand
if we ignore those deaths in chicago
they don't they go away those bodies
it's almost like jesus they're
resurrected three days later and they
come back to their communities chains
men and individuals and they turn water
into wine
were you uh shocked at all i suspect not
over what happened over the last couple
weeks with the larry elder campaign in
california i mean the media treated him
absolutely horribly
times he's a black white supremacist
joe biden on stage refusing to say his
name
calling him a trump clone the guy was
born in south central his dad was a
janitor barack obama doing a hit video
on him without even mentioning his name
again uh did any of that shock you i
mean when when you see a black person
who happens to fall somewhat in your
political space
the the abuse i assume you're beyond
shock at this point right
yeah i'm not shocked
what happened to larry elder though what
shocked me was
my initial gut reaction it was like
well larry elder ain't got no shot at
they're not going to recall newsome and
then when i saw the la times and
everybody like
viciously going after him i was like oh
my god he must have a chance to win
there's no they've unleashed the hounds
and and it made me take his campaign
more seriously
uh
i thought you didn't reference but
the woman the white woman in the gorilla
mask yeah that threw an egg at him
swung at his security guy and hit him in
the face someone ran up behind that same
security guy and kicked him in the rear
end
dave the only thing we can analogize
that to
is what we saw in the 1950s and 60s
and what the black people sitting at
lunch counters
and people treating them horrendously
that's what we were looking this white
woman put on a gorilla mask
and threw an egg at this man
and these
the hypocrisy of
the left
to not be apoc apocalyptic about this to
be
completely outward
there's not
no i know i know it's it's completely
trust me i was i was traveling with him
to say it's exasperating it's not even
the right word it's like how dare you
guys doesn't make cnn doesn't make msnbc
doesn't make the new york times
it but la times l.a times managed to
manipulate a photo of him so it looked
like he was hitting a woman as they were
claiming there was an incident in venice
an incident where a guerrilla woman
threw an egg at him that's what these
people do
i don't
i'm trying to think of what
the racial equivalent has been in terms
of racial politics over
uh the last few years have we seen any
anybody else treated this way and for
corporate media to ignore it
uh
is mind-boggling and it it it's
it's why
trump supporters believe the media is
the enemy of the people
because
the media not being a referee being an
affair arbiter
is what creates the racial divide and
animosity that's running wild in this
country when there are people
we've turned
half the country
into the voiceless
because i if
and it's not even it's not just trump
supporters it's people like me
who my crime is not hating trump yep i'm
not a trump supporter i just don't hate
him yeah i i don't really politics ain't
really my thing i don't i don't vote for
anybody i never have
my crime oh you don't hate trump
and and so those of us that either
support trump or don't hate trump
we have no voice in corporate media
i you know
i guess fox news
is but but we're so overwhelmed
by the rest and and i look at
the people that are supposed to be
journalists and the outlets that claim
they're journalists and and the people
that think they're doing all the i'm on
the right side of history
no you're not no again
you may write you may have hannah nicole
jones in the new york times write a fake
history
uh
but but you're not on the right side of
history
uh
we're supposed the media
should be out
virtually every day try what is the
frustration why are people turning to
trump why did they turn to a reality tv
star
what are we doing wrong
what are politicians not offering the
people
that trump is filling that void we
should be explaining that and giving
these people a voice and making them
feel
uh
important and like
represented in this country
and then they would start looking for
different solutions but if trump's their
only option they're going to take it out
of desperation
well said all right i got i got one more
for you because i know this was on your
mind because this is what you had
reached out to me about about a couple
weeks ago and i've been talking a bit
about bill maher lately on the show you
you know me i was a big liberal big
lefty i can't quite say that anymore
actually in reality i'm probably still a
liberal but we don't really exist
anymore but but your argument i think is
that bill at this point is probably just
a conservative something to that effect
it's an argument i've kind of been
making for a while too that on all of
the important things he no longer is a
lefty but he's part of the hollywood
machine and what frustrates me is i
always see all the people on the right
crediting him every time he says
something sane but then at the same time
he will keep telling people to vote for
adam schiff and vote for joe biden and
vote in all of the people that are
destroying everything
i don't want to lead you too much there
so i'll just hand it to you
what do we do with these liberals what
do we do with these people
well
one of the things i suggested dave
is and
i don't know how i feel about it i just
kind of threw it out as a question
and it it ties in nicely to what i was
just saying
is
bill mars the fig leaf he's covering
himself with is trump
is is
his allegiance to the democratic party
at this point
seems to be totally based on hatred of
trump
and
anytime you argue with somebody on the
left
they avoid getting into a substantive
discussion with you by playing the trump
card i like to call
and they just talk about trump and and
so i've asked myself the question like
if trump
backed away and said you know what i'm
exiting politics
i'm going to help ron desantis
josh holly i don't whoever someone else
if trump backed away would that be like
pulling the chair out from underneath
the left and making them fall on their
ass
and make them have to actually deal with
the things that they're doing
and if they had to actually deal with
the things they were doing and they
weren't allowed to say trump trump trump
trump because the the thing that put me
over the top was bill maher is on his
show and he's got some woman on from the
la times
she's some kind of washington
correspondent and he's talking about how
like oh my god joe biden just screwed up
afghanistan
there's no way it could have
it could have been handled any worse
and he tosses it to this woman she goes
well it could be worse trump could be
and i was just like
well he ain't there for one and bill
maher disagrees like what no he couldn't
have been worse with trump and just cut
it out
trump is the only thing they have
and i'm just wondering if it was taken
away
would they collapse on top of their
illogic and idiocy
but you're saying in that regard that
that he's kind of there because in that
case he he didn't say it could be worse
with trump i i think i would probably
argue that back in the day they used to
tell you that george w bush was a racist
and and evil and all of those things and
let's not forget mitt romney hated women
he had a binder of women like they
always got somebody trump is just the
the special somebody but for me it's
like get to the end of the road man just
get to the end of the road the
conservatives aren't coming for you you
may disagree with them on abortion you
may disagree with them on religion but
they're not coming for you the other
guys are coming for everything you hold
hold dear
and so
the thing i wanted to ask you is do you
see
similarities between yourself
and bill maher in terms of has bill
maher been red peeled
is he going down the path where
eventually
he's going to have to admit
that he's no longer what he used to be
well let's do this i'll give you the 30
second answer here and then we'll do the
rest of it on your show fair enough fair
enough
all right so the 30-second answer is yes
i believe he's basically been fully
red-pilled i it's so obvious to me it's
ridiculous but he's in hollywood he's a
mainstay of 30 years standard bearer of
leftism and he's got a career and he has
a legacy that he's trying to protect and
i think he knows he's in his last couple
years of this run and he's going man
would i flip at this point and i've been
calling all of these people backwards
idiots for being believers and i hate
religion and blah blah blah and and
suddenly they're the ones that are
protecting me he's at the end of what i
would say liberalism
has wrought unfortunately purely secular
liberalism and and he's up against that
and yet his his intellect has been red
pilled so how do you how do you
negotiate between your red pilled
intellect and the reality of your life
at a certain age
that would be my sort of psych 101 but
we can unpack that further on your show
yeah i think he's in a tough spot
because it's not even just hollywood
he'd have to give up probably a lot of
his friends
and his social circle
and
you know
he's
you don't want to do that well jason i'm
pretty sure i'm pretty sure you know
just as well as i know that when you
give up some of those people you
actually get better friends on the other
side usually i i know that's the case
for me and i guess for youtube riley you
get friends that are actually really
with you and they're not with you over
politics they're all with you because
you know
content of your character in your heart
whitlock you are fearless and i will be
a guest on fearless in the near future
i'm away next week i'm away for a couple
days but then i will do the show we'll
pick up right where we left off i'm
gonna wait for bill maher to say
something controversial again and then
i'm gonna put the request in and and
dave i gotta be honest with you
i put a lot of pressure on you i just
gave you my a plus material for an hour
straight and so uh you gotta return the
favor
i will caffeinate heavily that day
all right the show is fearless blaze tv
wet luck i'll see you soon
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell